all right everyone we're back with
Naveen Jane we are now going to be
talking about abundance versus scarcity
so tell us a bit about this yeah think
about it only reason we believe the
things have value is somehow we believe
they are finite and people fight over
things because they somehow believe that
if I have it someone else doesn't have
it or if someone else has it I can't
have it they are in finite quantity so
we value those things so what is it that
we fight over we fight over land we
fight over energy and we fight over
water because somehow we believe they
are scarce now imagine what is it that
we don't fight over the things we
absolutely believe are in abundance and
lot of people will say you know what
humans are just greedy it doesn't matter
how much we have we always want more
until they are reminded that we can sit
in a stadium seventy five thousand of us
and we can cheer and never fight over
air the air and oxygen we believe are in
abundance so guess what happens we don't
value it it's free for everyone is
Democrat eyes is demonetised
and we all enjoy it imagine if the
energy was the next air it was free and
it was available to everyone and it is
quite possible remember every 90 minutes
more solar energy falls on this planet
our planet Earth then we use in the
whole year simply a matter of conversion
yes and when that conversion happens
similar to what happened in the
aluminium it used to be the most
expensive material until the technology
called electrolysis came about and it
became so cheap that we throw it away it
was so expensive this was the material
they use Napoleon used to serve the King
of Siam
this is the material we used in the top
of the Washington Monument because this
needs to be so scarce and here we are
today we are actually giving it away
throwing it away right now imagine once
we get the electrolysis of solar energy
we were going to throw the energy away
it is going to be so abundance is going
to be free and when we have free energy
you get free fresh clean water because
the dirtiest water in Africa you can
distillate and imagine if you can have
abundance of free water abundance of
free energy abundance of free food
wouldn't that be the life worth living
and I believe that is just the beginning
same way we're going to create abundance
of land because we live on one single
planet let's look at think this way
we're living on a single spacecraft the
spacecraft is called planet Earth is
flying around in the space imagine if
our spacecraft gets damaged we all other
species will die yes there's no reason
we can't live on moon Mars Europa Titan
or beyond and it's exciting it's my dear
and people talk about all the problems
you can't live on the moon and you can't
live on the Mars because they have
radiation and humans can live in high
radiation that is the mindset of
scarcity and here's why the nature has
already solve many of these problems we
find the bacterial organisms living and
thriving in radioactive nuclear waste
that means Nature has figured out how to
protect its DNA from radiation and use
the radiation as a source of energy so
imagine if you can take those genes from
those bacteria use CRISPR to modify our
own genes suddenly not only we become
the radiation resistant we don't need to
eat food anymore
because radiation is all we will need in
the evening you're gonna say hey honey
do you want to go out for a walk and get
some radiation you don't need the food
anymore and that's the kind of
possibilities right and there's just one
of the many ways we can do that all I'm
trying to say is the technology is
available all it takes is the
imagination for someone to say enough is
enough let's go do it and those are the
people who move the society forward yes
and I like how you went right at the
throat of this mentality of scarcity
being about having finite resources but
then you gave that amazing an awareness
to air
and how that we it's all we all have can
tap into air for free cuz it's abundant
and then if we can have that same sort
of mentality with water and food and
energy and education and healthcare I
mean we're just gonna just flourish
maximize our potential and one more that
I think is really interesting I want to
hear your take on this regarding
abundance is once we get to the point of
being able to manipulate matter with
nanotechnologies and artificial
intelligence these blueprints for these
different objects in just car and that
kind of stuff it it doesn't preclude me
from having that ability to morph or
whatever I want
yeah is if you have it it doesn't
preclude me from having it absolutely
correct and this comes back to the
mindset right the mindset of how do you
create in finite opportunity from the
finite resources right and they're only
only reason we believe the resources are
finite is because we can't see them we
believe there is no other galaxy because
we don't see it we believe there is no
other universe because we can't fathom
it right but there is absolutely no
reason to believe they don't exist right
I mean you know it is the only thing we
believe is that what we can see what if
what we see is actually not real and
that is itself is it I would say virtual
itself right so you could argue that we
all live in this virtual reality to
begin with and then we start to give
meaning to reality yeah yep and the
mindset of abundance is going to propel
us forward I love it Naveen yeah so I
think mindset of abundance
and them as we discussed before this
idea of to be able to imagine to do
something big imagine and doing
something crazy imagine and being crazy
yep and then that crazy is going to
build the future yep awesome